surtout que maintenant on accueille un
grand écrivain français max gallo
je garde mon choix bonsoir laurent
baffie
je connais vitrine y joue nailloux ben
voilà max gallo alors napoléon mesurait
un mètre cinquante neuf de vol 1 m 93 et
vous un mètre quatre-vingt-treize aussi
non c'est simple quand vous dites est
grand ça vous aide à cacher aux autres
votre timidité vous impressionner alors
que vous êtes dans l'état d'esprit d'un
an on trouve quand même c'est pas votre
genre ça c'est cette humidité
non c'est une humilité cacher avant puis
au moins sur un an joue un peu quoi vous
me rassurez parce que franchement en
fait en question ne vous êtes plutôt ce
qu'on pourrait appeler aujourd'hui un
géante pas de la littérature mais
d'édition en tous les cas vous sûreté
quoi je sais pas quand mais combien de
livres par an là depuis quelques années
entre napoléon 2 ou 3 2 ou 3 par deux ou
trois par an les ventes très très bien
d'ailleurs été 70 livre v mois 170 bien
alors nous on parlait du destin de mouna
ayoub qui est assez extraordinaire parce
que passionnant parce que bon il vient
très beau livre à écrire d'article en
gamme et seulement mais nous la
connaissons le fera elle même
je ne sais pas si l'idéal écrit monnaie
déjà mené au bon goût mais vous aussi
vous avez un destin extraordinaire parce
que finalement fils d'immigrés italiens
vivant à nice
marié un libanais non on a résisté à
vous dit tu as très bon père bon fils
d'immigrés italiens votre père armand
vous ai dit que votre père était employé
de banque mais on mon père était
électricien a travaillé dans une borne
musiciens il ya des moments où bon je
suis un peu laissé passer ça comme ça
j'ai dix employés de banque c'était plus
simple c'est trop compliqué brême enfin
bon c'est à dire la vérité vous votre
premier diplôme c'est un diplôme de
mécanicien ajusteur c'est bien c'est une
success story que vous allez tracé de ma
vie moi ce qui nous intéresse ici avec
catherine barma
si le destin des gens c'est vrai c'est
la biographie des gens l'histoire a fait
irruption l'histoire avec un grand h a
fait irruption dans votre vie quand vous
avez vu deux résistants pendu à un
lampadaire est ce que c'est vrai ça oui
non c'est vrai je crois que pour un
enfant mais ce devait être pareil pour
les enfants libanais pour les enfants
aujourd'hui du kosovo
un enfant reçoit la guerre comme une
tragédie qui peut le mutiler et en même
temps je crois qu'il voit la guerre
comme un grand jeu c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à tous les instants il
ya quelque chose d'inédit
on voit des soldats qui passent on voit
des tanks convoi des avions qui
bombardent
et puis brusquement on est face à la
tragédie
et moi j'ai vu le 25 juillet 1944
j'avais une douzaine d'années j'ai vu
comme ça pendre à deux lampadaires de
résistants qu'on a fait monter sur une
c'est pas gai mais autant le dire qu'on
a fait que les allemands ont fait monter
sur des toits de camionnette puis la
camionnette est parti ils sont resté
pendu alors vous commencé à écrire à
l'âge de 16 ans et à 22 ans un peu près
de classe sociale vous hésitez à un an
avant d'entrer à la sorbonne à lormont
ayouba n'a pas hésité à y aller
directement à l'été avec c'est la
visionnant moi c'est la sorbonne
vous hésitiez vous disais c'est pas pour
moi il y avait donc j'hésite est si
j'avais c'était tellement impressionnant
enfin impressionnant comme mythologie
comme symbole que la première année
aujourd'hui tout ça est modifié parce
que les étudiants se comptent par par
millions donc mais disons que dans les
années 50 la sorbonne c'était la
sorbonne moi je n'ai pas osé franchir la
voûte a veillé à droite il y avait la
porte de la loge de la concierge qui
vendait les programmes
je me suis arrêté là j'ai acheté
d'acheter le programme et puis j'ai
utilisé en fonction du programme j'ai
évidemment étudié
alors aujourd'hui bon vous écrivez vous
faites plus qu écrire d'ailleurs on
verra un petit peu plus tard ce que vous
avez fait avant mais là pour le moment
fait plus qu écrire vous dites je ne
sais plus faire que ça finalement nous
vivait avec un pied dans l'imaginaire un
pied dans la un pied dans la réalité
alors là c'est incroyable ça fait
flipper beaucoup de gens ça max gallo
écrit quand même dix heures par jour 15
févier par jour samedi et dimanche
compris
six heures de sommeil l'ema 3h30 cheval
à 3h30 oui très bien renseignés pas
beaucoup de mérite pas ce que vous dites
quand j'écris pas j'ai des migraines et
des sifflements dans les oreilles de
toute façon donc ses deux buts seconde
nature
voilà alors maintenant on va parler de
votre livre
voilà un nom max gallo bleu blanc rouge
c'est une trilogie 1
c'est le premier tome qui s'appelle
marie est là alors c'est pour résumer la
situation ces deux siècles d'histoire de
france à travers le destin de ces
familles oui c'est une manière de c'est
tout le monde connaît sans connaître
l'histoire de france parce que
l'histoire de france c'est bon c'est un
programme scolaire c'est ennuyeux etc
or pour moi l'histoire est peut-être à
cause de ce que vous avez rappelé parce
que pour moi ça d'abord été ce que j'ai
vu avec des yeux d'enfant pour moi
l'histoire c'est essentiellement des
gens vivent donc là mon projet c'était
de faire revivre en racontant les vies
de six personnages dans les années au
moment où ça commence pour la france
contemporaine
c'est à dire au moment de la révolution
française et puis de suivre ces familles
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mes sens en théorie
bien les personnages principaux
maximilien forestier soldats de la
révolution qui va terminer maréchal
d'empiré et guillaume du cerf lui c'est
le [ __ ] [ __ ] jake one way fait de
l'argent je dirai évidemment oui malgré
ma voisine ou à cause de ma voisine elle
serait prudent dans ce domaine mais il
fait de l'argent il fait de l'argent
voilà
taurignan préfère sert couper la tête
que relancer à ses idées et finalement
ce que vous dites c'est il ya deux
choses qui m'ont intéressé dans votre
bouquin la première notion c'est la
notion de transbordement c'est-à-dire ce
moment où l'argent passe d'une classe
sociale à une autre et finalement où des
gens des bourgeois et d'aidé et
est parvenu finalement achètent des
châteaux achètent des choses des
enchères trucs et donc c'est bien bien
sûr on vit dans des sociétés aujourd'hui
par exemple en france une société stable
chacun est plus ou moins à sa place il
ya des réussites rapide puis imaginez
que tout ça comme ce ver tombe par terre
et se casse c'est qu'il faut une image
thema faire une image tombe par terre et
se casse il ya des gens qui vont prendre
les bons morceaux et des gens qui vont
au contraire avoir un morceau de verre
dans le pied et la révolution française
et pendant au fond une cinquantaine
d'années en france ça a été ça ça a été
des femmes qui essayaient de sauver leur
tête en épousant officiers républicains
ça a été un officier républicain qui aux
enchères acheter un château a donc été
un transbordement employer le mot un
transbordement de fortune un peu comme
par exemple puis tout salariale
mystérieux comme en russie quand le
communisme est effondrée il ya eu un
transbordement de fortune de pouvoir la
deuxième chose dont vous parlez aussi à
travers ce premier tome c'est vous les
girouettes vite en 1820 est paru un
dictionnaire des girouettes sert
effectivement les gens qui ont vécu
cette période on était obligé de changer
d'avis ont été obligés de changer de
position parce que de toute façon les
régimes a tellement vite que commencer
avec le père la position 36 15 cole
morgan
c'était des pauses belhassine début j'ai
jamais vu comme ça je mesure mes moon a
voulu fait un ep non on vous dit c'est
une époque où les gens finalement été
obligé d'une certaine façon de changer
d'avis parce que changer d'avis ou on
perd 17 et 26 ha oui donc logique qu'on
génère beaucoup oui j'en changer d'avis
vous aussi vous avez changé d'avis ça
m'est arrivé oui non mais avec moi avec
vous je me souviens très bien oui tout à
fait avec moi je me souviens c'était une
émission c'est vers ses apostrophes
oublier décret khalid qui s'appelait
louis 20 libre disons pas défendre la
monarchie mais montrant l'actualité
l'idée monarchique à la fin du xxème
siècle et vous m'avez attaquer mais
d'une façon terrible vous m'avez j'ai eu
le sentiment d'être attaquée d'une façon
allemand perd quand vous avez été d'une
séance terne et sans mise à l'écart du
jeu a été d'une habileté perfide
insupportable en dérive d'ailleurs il
avait fait le plateau je crois que ça
s'est jamais produit n'est pas le genre
de la naissance
ces jeux ça s'est jamais produit
apostrophe chaque fois que je parlais
j'ai été sifflé et chaque fois qu'il
parlait il était appelé parce qu'il
avait simplement raison c'est simplement
parce que le plateau à les effets à sa
main quoi on peut le penser on n'agit
pas j'allais dire chenu avec moi sur
wade et moi non alors à l'époque je
pense va pas refaire les missions parce
que c'est il ya quatorze ans dont
quatorze ans il ya 14 ans il ya
prescription mais je vous dis je vous
disais par exemple vous disait par
exemple que louie louie 17 le fils de
louis saez les cg ollier le faisait
boire de l'alcool pour lui faire avouer
que ce qu'il avait que sa mère l'avait
obligé à coucher avec elle magnéto serge
je ne sais pas si c'est la peine de
débattre je peux dire comment prendre au
sérieux un livre bourré de formules du
genre la monarchie lave plus blanc
pourquoi pas si le nouveau stick moi je
veux bien aller pêcher je souris je
trouve ça très très très très
intéressant et aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui vous dit
quatorze ans après la révolution
finalement et moi mythologique on nous
l'a enseigné
mais j'ai pas c'est pas contradictoire
ah bon vous avez mis de l'eau dans votre
vin sur la révolution française max
gallo disons que je suis descendu
davantage dans le tout doux et que je
regardais comment le vin était constitué
très bien voilà alors vous aussi en
politique vous avez gipa outre été de
girouette mais enfin vous avez quand
même évolué vous avez commencé aux
jeunesses communistes en 74 d'entre eux
au ps
oui après la défaite de mitterrand aux
élections présidentielles de 80 à 83
faisait député ps des alpes-maritimes et
ensuite porte parole du gouvernement
mauroy
vous avez été remplacé par roland dumas
d'air et en 90
vous commencez à trouver on vit en avant
non mais mais cette évolution est
incontestable c'est vrai que je suis
passé d'une vision on peut dire marxiste
communiste de ma jeunesse qui étaient
dictées par et je ne la récuse pas parce
que quand on veut comprendre le
comportement des gens il faut savoir
d'où ils viennent ce qu'ils sont qu'ils
étaient dictés par le sentiment de
l'humiliation au fond j'étais à tort ou
à raison je me vivait comme d'humilier
un offensé au fur et à mesure que je
faisais des études et non pas que je
changeais de casse sociale
le feu à mesure que je faisais des
études ben je lisais des livres et
lisant des livres je découvrais ce que
ce que ce qui avait été fait en 36 en
russie etc
donc je me suis totalement dégagée dès
les années 55 de cet arrêt de cette
première de cette première imprégnation
et quant aux quant à mon passage dans le
gouvernement socialiste
il était en effet le sentiment que
c'était un moment important pour
l'alternance et je continue à penser que
l'alternance
aujourd'hui je pense que ça a été un
moment positif sur ce plan là est le
moment où la société française a
commencé à se décomposer
peut-être parce que le sommet de la de
pouvoir voilà peut-être parce que le
sommet de ce pouvoir là tenait des
discours qui correspondait pas à ce
qu'il faisait dans la rue en l'argent
qui sale et l'argent qui corrompt voilà
voilà
mais on connaît vous connaissez on
connaît très bien non mais aujourd'hui
en tout cas je vous devance aujourd'hui
ma position c'est que je suis ce qu'on
appelle un républicain comme tant
d'autres
et surtout je crois que il faut
conserver à ce qui nous entoure c'est à
dire la nation française
une réalité il faut savoir que ça a été
construit péniblement pendant des
siècles par des gens qui en est fait
était ce qui soulève le petit louis 17
et puis des gens qui au contraire
étaient prêts à mourir pour essayer de
faire évader louis saez
il y avait les chouans il y avait pu y
avait les bleus et puis avec les blancs
tout ça a fait un pays contradictoires
pas toujours satisfaisant mais un pays
qui a un visage singulier unique même
moins je mendie hongrois à l'exemple
brutale vers du jeanne d'arc
et puis il ya eu un évêque français qui
s'appelaient cochon le bien nommé qui a
fait condamner jeanne d'arc qu'ils
étaient tous les deux français
je suis plutôt du côté de jeanne d'arc
il n'empêche que si on veut comprendre
ce que c'est que la france il faut
savoir qu'à des aussi l'évêque mais
voilà voilà maintenant mais je gagne
c'est ça
il est
c'est bon maintenant mais je vais
beaucoup vous étonner je peux vous
étonner oui j'ai fait ma première
campagne électorale contre personnages
pleins de ma deuxième campagne
électorale contre jacques médecin maire
de nice près il ya aussi les
circonstances locales pousse à être
quelque chose quand vous avez en face de
vous un épouvantail un peu caricatural
c'était la chanson de ma campagne
électorale en 1983
il
m
j'adore cette chanson cinglé suis ravi
de me faire plaisir et maîtrise la
chanson c'était le pénitencier donc
aujourd'hui max gallo bâ oui vous êtes
proche de pasqua de charles pasqua
tu tiens giraud pas bon enfin je
comprends ses motivations au congrès
vous avez appelé quand même un peu à
voter pose alors j'ai dit que j'allais
voter pour lui ah oui pas appelé et m'a
fait d'accord maintenant je parle pour
moi seulement pour moi je suis mon
propre porte parole que je m'arrête à ça
et vous dit en parlant de vip de
villiers d'ailleurs c'est un républicain
dont la morale est exempte de tout
reproche
ce que je pense je pense que c'est un
personnage qui est caricaturé facilement
qui est peut-être à des faits parfois
ridicules mais je n'ai eu comme étudiant
quand j'étais prof à sciences po vous
voyez le hasard et je sais que c'est
quelqu'un qui est qui et honnête dans
son danseur dans son esprit je partage
pas ses valeurs mais il ya chez lui une
une fibre patriotique
un enracinement dans le pays que je
trouve un peu vulgaire de critiquer
sommairement là que je veux pas vous
affaler et vous avez tous les symptômes
de la maladie d'alzheimer c'est comment
ces jeunesses communistes et vous
finissez par an chance et des tâches à
ce que vous appelez ça un sens aimé vous
me l'avez peut-être alors des signes
graves de sénilité précoce sans le matin
en discute pas
viens on discutera non mais nous on
s'est beaucoup engueulé avec max gallo
de son niveau et puis maintenant
regardons née renée connaissez saison
avec galop max gallo bleu blanc rouge
comme l'essonne marie est là